this turned out so well though I mean
you know it really always comes down to
his Kevin says you got to see the movie
and love it and I saw I got I was in it
a little bit and and I saw and I
honestly loved it hey guys it's Charlie
this is going to be my early spider-man
homecoming no spoilers reaction review I
even got my spider-man t-shirt on I'll
rank my favorite spider-man films at the
end of this - because the movie isn't
coming out for a little while we'll do a
giveaway for IMAX gift certificates all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
and you do want to try and go see this
in IMAX
if you have that format available just
because of the way he moves the way they
use the camera if they were able to do
really cool first-person style looking
spider-man way back during Sam Raimi era
without getting into spoilers just think
about what that enables them to do with
this level of technology like they can
literally have Tony Stark walking around
on set with dots on him and then put the
suit on him in post-production he's
probably got the best job of all but the
good thing about this movie is that it
all feels very practical it feels real
in a way that spider-man movies haven't
in a while and that's where a lot of the
high school aspect of the character is
to its benefit so if you haven't seen
just you know flat-out pretty much
everybody that's been talking about the
movie loves it there's a lot of people
that are torn as to where it fits in the
spider-man canon like is this the best
spider-man movie ever is this the
second-best spider-man movie ever that's
really what you want to hear some people
are very precious about their classic
films like it's really hard to beat that
second Tobey Maguire film still one of
the best superhero films of all time of
any superhero film the thing that
differentiates this film from other
spider-man films and from the other
Marvel films just in general is that
high school aspect like they completely
nailed all the high school stuff it
actually feels like a real high school
it's not like the Disney Channel or the
gap version of high school like you
could actually walk into a high school
in New York City and it would feel just
like that they actually had Tom Holland
go pretend to be a student in a charter
school for a little while just that he
could get the feel for what it's like to
be a genuine American high school kid
because when he's British and - he's
been a child actor so most of the
learning that he's done that you would
get in school he
been doing on movie sets with tutors so
while you have seen high school Peter
Parker in previous spider-man film
typically it's the first actor the first
couple act of the films and you don't
spend a lot of time in the actual high
school setting like you see him in high
school for brief periods then most of
the time he's busy off being spider-man
they balanced that much better in this
film in the film is mostly all about
Peter Parker's identity who is
spider-man and who is Peter Parker Tom
Holland himself said that you know while
everybody loathes themselves a little
bit Peter Parker really does not like
being Peter Parker he wishes he could
just be spider-man the whole time in the
movie does a really good job of showing
you that and the other really cool thing
that differentiates this from the Marvel
films is the aspirational aspect to it
so he's 15 16 years old in this film
looking up at these heroes that he
admires but in the other Marvel films
even though there's a lot of optimism
there's hope you have the characters
wrestling with inner demons you meet
them in the Avengers and there's
absolutely no reason for them to be in a
room together each of them is sort of
like a mini God in their own right so or
himself as an actual god
spider-man is in no way a God of his
high school like he's had his powers for
about six months or so when the movie
picks up but he's just like any other
kid who happens to get powers but they
completely nail Peter Parker he's a
science geek he's a science bro in
training so whereas other spider-man
films do a really good job with a
spider-man character like a really
badass version of spider-man
I feel like this film also does an A+
job with Peter Parker and even though
there's been this funny thing where it
seems like it's popular to complain
about spoilery spider-man trailers there
were a lot of genuine surprises like
when Robert Downey jr. teased oh we've
got a couple surprises for you they
actually delivered on that they nailed
the third act which is usually the
Achilles heel of every big action movie
like they do really good and the first
half of the movie the second act is good
then as you get later in the movie the
big action set piece the climax that's
when it starts to fall apart and they
actually did a really good job and most
of that credit I think goes to the
vulture character who's probably one of
the best Marvel villains since Loki so
Michael Keaton's fantastic there's no
debating back we can't really talk about
what
since to his character without getting
into spoilers but I'll suffice to say
they used Tony Stark in a really good
way his presence in the trailers in the
marketing there's been a lot of funny
jokes about that Iron Man homecoming
that is no way indicative of his
relative presence in the film but they
did an amazing job of using his
character for the other characters
development and that's important
obviously for spider-man because he's
the Avenger hopeful and training and
also for the vultures character for his
villain arc so what is spider-man
without his friends
Ned Leeds was great he totally reminded
me of some of the best things about my
own high school best friends then daya
was an amazing complex character I know
there are a lot of theories about what's
going on with her most of them were
wrong there's still a lot of surprises I
feel like she'll be a really interesting
character in the next spider-man movie
the high school stuff could have been a
big problem because you spend so much
time there but I feel like whoever did
the casting for this movie really earn
their money because all those characters
were great and you cannot say enough
about Marisa Tomei is Aunt May I feel
like a lot of comments are mostly about
how their aging her down how she's like
the hot Aunt May aunt BAE right now but
they did a much better job of including
her in the actual movie like she's a
much more functional part of the plot
and what's going on with the spider-man
character then the Aunt May character
has been in previous spider-man films so
not only is she fantastic the movie also
finds better ways of using her than
they've used that character in previous
movies most of you probably know that
spider-man is going to be an infinity
war because they've been marketing it
that way he's been popping up with
Robert Downey jr. on set quite a bit
he'll be in the fourth Avengers film
then they've confirmed that the first
film after that fourth Avengers film
sort of like the first phase for film is
going to be spider-man homecoming 2 so
we'll do a separate video about that
next week just all about the phase 4
stuff Kevin Feige has been talking about
because they said that after that he's
going to be entering a whole different
Marvel Universe so that implies a whole
lot of things but it's not really
specific to what's going on with
spider-man homecoming but there's a lot
that's been made about the deal between
Marvel and Sony sharing the character
doing the next movie and then after that
then not having a deal in place so if
you were ever worried that spider-man
would leave the MCU the direct
recently came out and said note that's
never going to happen
it's just that they're taking the movies
one at a time Tom Holland since then has
come out and said yes it's going to be a
trilogy so whatever ends up happening
with Sony spider-verse the other
spin-off films that they're developing
whether they succeed whether they fail
spider-man will not leave the MCU Tom
Holland has said Robert Downey jr. style
he wants to play the character for the
next 10 years we'll see that actually
ends up happening but for those of you
that want like a more mature adult
spider-man he'll get there eventually
he'll just age into the character
naturally so just a place this film in
my favorite list of spider-man films
before this film it was spider-man 2
then Spiderman amazing spider-man
amazing spider-man 2 in spider-man 3
without having seen it a billion times
I'll say this is my new favorite
spider-man film I can re-watch
spider-man 2 over and over again like it
totally holds up so we'll see if my list
changes a little bit after I see
homecoming a couple more times but I
feel like there was nothing to worry
about like people weren't really sure
what to expect from Tom Holland what to
expect from a high school age Peter
Parker but I'm allowed to talk more in
depth about the movie this Thursday on
the 29th so that's when my bigger deeper
review the film will post no spoilers so
hopefully you guys get a chance to see
it really soon if you do have the
opportunity like I said try and see it
in the biggest format possible because
it is awesome in Michael Keaton slaves
he is amazing as the vulture and I
almost forgot you guys are asking about
post-credits scenes do stay through the
credits there are multiple post credits
scenes but no spoilers as to what those
are there's a bunch of Marvel stuff
happening in the next couple of days so
I'll announce the winner of the giveaway
when I post that phase 4 video it got a
little bit of flash coming up later
today but while you wait for everything
you can click here for all my spider-man
videos and you can click here for brand
new Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight